I have this really interesting 2017
challenge it is my belief that everybody
has a ton of chacas ton of former like
clothes ton of electronics general trim
finite iPhone but different generation
iPhones flip phone thank you hey rock
you know
deputy iPhone 4 sitting in your closet
you know a ram man one that's actually
from 84 that'll probably go for nine
bucks here's my big belief my big belief
is this my friends the 2017 flip
challenge is this I believe that if you
amass the hours that you allocate to a
you know I phone game for three hours
here to when you're on the bus commuting
for an hour instead of just reading
escapism is important but if you want
the twenty-one thousand dollars that I
think you'll get at the end of the year
and by the way we're gonna have a 21-7
family thing at the end love like a
$21,700 Club and everybody who's hit it
maybe we'll all get together at the end
of the year let me figured out by the
way I just changed my mind
it is twenty like it's two twenty
thousand one hundred seventy dollars the
2107 the $21,700 challenge means it's
the year 2170 yeah I was like what the
hell I was like driving in streams like
with anyway we're gonna have a twenty
thousand hundred twenty thousand one
hundred seventy dollar challenge no
cheating and you need to be fresh
there's a bunch of people like resi
resales and some of the other people
that already making tons of money
marshals employees think I'm Santa Claus
out here then in two thousand dollar
town shoot hahaha little do they know
I'm getting that online money new fresh
you've never done it before or you've
never masked more than five thousand
before and you're going to do this
nineteen thousand one hundred seventy
dollar challenge I believe if you take
that one hour when you're commuting and
actually search on eBay and search what
are clothes worth what are what are
hammers work like what is this hammer
work do you like you know which is
hammer go for well yeah yeah $7.99
better than zero
especially you'll have it yeah two
hammers $14 for the opening right here
working out
none but you can easily go search hammer
and you can go then completed items sold
items and see what people are doing it
tends back let's go out to gauge action
bruh real quick how many hours do you
think you put in researching eBay sold
complete how do we build our education
what do you how many hours really what
you realistically realize you tweeted
thousands right but it's not
I get excited sometimes I would say you
get pumped on Friday nights look at just
like to really like hours just that on
Friday nights me tha would literally be
on instant messenger back in a day pre
mobile and and write premium lives and
mister I love to get his IV semester
Darryl launcher yeah we literally would
stick like we would have to get up and I
we looked far away I was in New York he
was in 100 and County New Jersey I would
go and drive you oh no we met amends but
I don't feel cuz you were driving now
anyway nonetheless let me to have to get
up for our who's have to get up at four
o'clock in the morning five o'clock in
the morning to go to these flea markets
and then garage sales and at midnight I
will extending each other link like wait
a minute marbles are worth a lot of
money but ins and jars have any video
games what do you think air looks the
best you think you do
I like it anyway take every hour every
hour this year to make this 21 a I would
say 150 to 300 hours okay great but I
must go even and mother we only did in
like 15 categories it's an every movie a
vote because you want to be in a
position if you're if you want to buy
mugs you got to be in a position that
when you walk into a garage sale and
they have 40 mugs and they're asked to
five bucks apiece you'll be able to
cherry pick two of them so that's why
they should be a team expertly but but
AJ the thing that's changed huge today
champ enough right look you have your
phone you can look it up yeah you know
40 to 200 boys and girls all the pieces
to 150 they make 150 bucks in ten
seconds at 7:30 in the morning set
easier you have a phone on you you take
your phone you take the eBay app you can
literally scan some items of able UPC
but if not you just search Flintstones
mug you go to completed items you see
how much it's sold for how often it's
sold understand the supply and demand of
the market and if the person by the way
mugs are a quarter and not five bucks at
garage sells their order maybe a dollar
and you're like I'll give you 50 cents
and you can make nine bucks it's also
great hobby but most of all here's the
punchline so many of you are trying to
build a business and you're begging for
money you're crippled by not having
money I have a huge community now on
social networks and ER I don't know how
many people wouldn't want to have 20,000
170 dollars extra in their pocket and a
lot of you have bigger ambitions I know
a lot of you were about to say all this
is small I don't need it it's taking
away time I can be working on my
business I don't want to take time away
from your business I don't want to
taking time away from your family I want
to take your time away from other dumb
[ __ ] if you're complaining if you don't
complain and you don't want the 20,000
$170 then do you play call of duty
watch [ __ ] every bowl game but if
you're complaining and you're struggling
and you're hungry and you can't breathe
because you want to win like me well
then do this because every one of you
has a foundation of between 500 and
$5,000 worth of junk in your closet
attic and garage basement right now
every one of you it's insane even the
poorest of us in America have
stuff laying around a jacket you're not
wearing anymore sneakers that are out of
style those sneakers go for 19 bucks I
mean here ugh I really need you to
spread a bunch of stuff from like the
social networks like screens here while
I'm yapping I want people to see I made
200 bucks today I made 700 bucks day I
made 38 bucks today the key is doing
your homework the one thing I want to
make sure I've seen a lot of you post
and be successful but you've sold your
product for half the price because you
created a Buy It Now price that is half
the price of it's worth this image that
I sent the rack completed and sold items
you have to understand that you have to
understand what things sell for and you
have to understand if they sell the
reason completed matters is you can see
58 people didn't sell that you know
goofy toy and one person got sold it for
18 bucks and that's why you can't price
it at 18 bucks buy it now and think it's
just going to sell because its supply
and demand is off it always comes down
to the work this is the most practical
real advice that I've given that
actually generates dollars it is
massively important if you want to be
successful life to know and try and
learn how to make money if you don't
learn that you are vulnerable and any
business or anything that you create and
so I'm very excited about this young and
old learning this craft because you
learn supply and demand you learn market
conditions you learn speed of execution
you learn so many things this is the
foundational execution of how AJ was
built as a kid
so I'm excited about you doing it but
please make sure you do the work and
you're so many of you already I'm seeing
it are pricing things way too early way
too high and stuffs not selling because
you miraculously think people are gonna
overpay and way too low because you're
pumped to sell this sweater for $33 but
it was worth 57 so there strategies of
listing it at $0.99 and letting the
market take over but if you're not good
at listing the name putting out the
title you may not you may spell
something wrong or not put the extra
thing or not even know the nuance of it
there's millions of people probably not
there's tens of thousands people
searching on eBay for your missplay
right so do your homework learn search
learn how to search play within it I can
put you there but you've got to take
over and do the work to understand that
market place so put in those hours learn
and don't be crippled don't be crippled
that you sold a sweater for 3357 those
learning experiences are good
so that's the punchline that's a
challenge 19100 $70 in my opinion easily
made easily made this year if you take
the three to five hundred hours that you
were going to throw directly in the
trash doing jack [ __ ] and applying it to
becoming educated and learning the
markets we didn't get into buying stuff
on Craigslist then flipping it on eBay
buying stuff on eBay and then selling it
on Facebook marketplace Facebook
marketplace I think is a huge arbitrage
a lot of people don't know they're just
posting stuff by their sell on eBay
there's also all these flipping apps
let's go let go or something I got I got
to do the homework but everything always
matters the photos matter posting it on
social matters but don't spam people
that because you'll lose them selling
them on on Craigslist or Facebook
Marketplace or Etsy matters buying
t-shirts on eBay and then selling them
as thrifty vintage stuff on Etsy may
create a huge arbitrage and you don't
have to go garage saleing and Good Will
Hunting and so like it's amazing how
many things matter do you rock and I
were just talking about the questions
that are coming in these are Google
about don't ask me don't ask resi
resells who's crushing it google it like
it's all there it's just the work you
want me to answer you in DM form real
quick you could have gotten the answer
in four seconds if you actually put in
the fifteen minutes to click 17
different links and read and watch a
couple of videos or read an article or
two and I do believe that an enormous
amount of people in my community can
make twenty six thousand one hundred
seventy dollars this year converting
leisure time into flipping time going to
Goodwill going to garage sales we're
going to go hard we're gonna do some
garage sale videos this summer this
spring d-roc and that's the challenge
ahead
[Music]
ad-rock hey Gary
John Gianni here at developed them on
Instagram with my son Lex so you wanted
to know about selling these things on
eBay I grabbed this here at a garage
sale in my neighborhood for five dollars
in less than 24 hours I ended up selling
it for 20 on eBay
once I did that my son Lex sold these
two video games for $4 a piece thanks
Gary
thanks for all you guys do have a great
day real though I just dropped two G's
on some shoes I'm mad at myself I
thought it was gonna be 3 G's I wasn't
keeping track about to pull up and get
some pizza on the business card you know
it goes when you drop a couple of G's
you got to get some pepperoni new cheese
ah Gary taking your advice and selling
my collectibles from childhood to help
on my new company hey Gary
d-roc I'm on a roll with eBay and also
Craigslist let's start with Craigslist
yesterday morning I sold two couches I
put them on Craigslist they were gone by
five o'clock yesterday made 400 bucks
and now the eBay I got these Christmas
inflatables got the ugly Christmas
sweater got a guy coming to meet me give
me 40 bucks I got a couple more on eBay
one's going for $95 seriously thanks
Gary in four five and more